I have no idea of the story is a story
so far is that there's a mysterious
female who's sort of a robot what I
think the vexer know what she wasn't
part of the vex though what are the
robot people calls auntie Vic know the
people that you can make though that are
robots what does that raise called
that's nadia woken is it that's not know
the awoken were the ones in the reef
well whatever they are she was sort of
like following us for the beginning of
the game and then revealed herself as a
robot person and was sort of like
guiding us along to find out where the
heart of darkness is she's definitely a
guardian yes yeah I found that out yeah
she is she is not from light um so we we
struck a deal with the awoken yeah
that's what we did and we I think we
just killed the vex core or whatever get
we got the vex scores what they wanted
to make the trade their high mind we
could get the key to then get to Venus
yeah oh and that's kind of protection
impression is all that much story
impressions you know russian store or I
don't know this gives us a lot of fun
man um I feel like the different planets
in the different new zones feel
different enough from beta that I'm
excited to play the rest of this game
because it doesn't just feel like the
moon with a different skin the different
environments feel relatively different
at least um I know combat feels good
feels hey Louie similar to beta doesn't
feel like they completely overhauled it
or anything it does it does seem a
little bit like mechanically repetitive
yeah like these boss fights really are
essentially almost identical yeah for
sure um there's a lot on it looks great
it is like yes you deploy ghosts you
fight horde yap Legos to fight board
that seems to be the formula here but it
I'm not sick of it yet no so I mean it's
I really I'm kind of hoping that I mean
everyone saying this the whole time we
were playing to that you know
see the significant the deploy goes and
then stuff comes yeah uh so hopefully
the next people that sit down get a get
a different feel of what they have to
fight boss wise cuz it's really been a
lot of go to a point one stuff yeah it
feels real times long on stuff and then
go to a point you know they'll flip the
order on you I don't know maybe right
there yes ibly think that's that's about
the end of our second block of destiny
yeah we're streaming till five and
probably way beyond depending on how
much game content there is so bring it
on in crew number three two nights
returning how many
hold position kill the engines and don't
let the party